I have here just for a little bit of fun
the latest New South Wales economics
exam oh good I've said a few of these
over the years I did high school
economics but these are fairly standard
questions you know how we manag to
navigate the global financial crisis
without going into recession I put that
down to a Queensland high school
education using brown as the textbooks
on macro and micro my own observation
about um education learning is that I'm
still sufficiently oldfashioned to
believe there are things called
objective facts and that these things
are quantifiable they exist on the the
basis of evidence either in the physical
sciences or the social sciences there's
a difference between facts and my
opinion about the facts and that goes to
the whole domain of social media today
and some of the broader media which
conflate fact with opinion education's
ability to establish what are facts and
to cause people to conclude that I can
have different opinions about those
facts but they're separate from facts
that kind of helps hold our democracies
together as well